hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight all
right the billionaires brawl maybe up in
the air but Elon musk's still egging on
Zuckerberg so coming up
I get into the octagon with MMA Legend
Colby Covington and he shows me what
both men should expect
but first
where real Crime Pays that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
now while Democrats pursue political
prosecutions against former president
Trump real criminals are wreaking havoc
across the country
now given the pathetic leadership in
places like San Francisco Chicago
Washington DC and New York hardened
criminals feel emboldened heck they feel
Unstoppable
now you're watching a vicious attack
that occurred in broad daylight against
Rand Paul's staffer Philip Todd back in
March on 8th Street Northeast and that's
not far from where yours truly once
lived he was stabbed in the head
unprovoked allegedly by a man who was
released from prison a day prior
the video was just released Mr Todd
ended up with a fractured skull
as Democrats spend tens of millions of
dollars Lord knows how much every year
to investigate one man violent criminals
are terrifying D.C residents I just
thanks God to survive because you know
it was not easy I can't believe I
survived as well when I saw the video
after and after I keep looking myself
look for my hand you know do like this
just try to believe I'm I'm alive
I mean for some reason God saved me
he's an Uber driver from Iraq
too many haven't been saved though DC's
murder rate is the highest it's been in
two decades in response have we seen a
change in the permissive attitude
policies laws toward crime that frankly
destroyed what were so many once
habitable you know nice to live urban
areas no none of that's happened instead
we get meaningless platitudes from
Democrat Mayors like DC's Muriel Bowser
know uh that many common sense Solutions
are necessary to fill the gaps in our
Public Safety ecosystem we also know
that we continue to need a policy
environment that supports effective
enforcement and reduces crime and we
will continue to work with the council
to make sure we have the right policies
tools laws and Investments to drive down
crime
notice she doesn't address the problem
of repeat offenders including the thug
who was arrested for abusing women even
the Washington Post can't avoid
reporting on this one saying a Man
released from detention after being
charged with inappropriately touching
three women on Sunday in Northwest
Washington was arrested again two days
later accused of sexually abusing three
more women in broad daylight near
downtown
and reminiscent of the violence plaguing
the New York Subway system a man was
killed right by the Columbia Heights
Metro station last night that's in an
upcoming neighborhood with plenty of
trendy restaurants by the way
and even the area around Kamal is alma
mater Howard University that's not safe
a massive brawl left one student stabbed
and others injured earlier this week one
of the victims told a local station I
was prepared to die when I was on the
ground getting stomped out I just
stopped feeling the pain at one point
now these are our kids
now as a former longtime resident of DC
I am both saddened and frankly just
enraged that politicians let this happen
and that the voters still haven't gotten
the message
Democrats are destroying our cities
starting a lot but they're definitely
destroying our cities
but frankly it's not just the big cities
wild attacks are happening in small town
America as well like Middletown
Connecticut where a police officer was
overwhelmed by a hammer wielding nut
that ran at her full speed
stop stop
did she hesitate to shoot him because
she was worried about being prosecuted
herself and the anti-cop atmosphere that
has swept the country
and who knows
but you gotta Wonder
now as for New York it's become one big
giant psych ward except where the
patients are armed and where there are
no Burly attendance to restrain them
the following is an example of what
police in New York have to deal with all
too regularly this is a 31 year old
freak who sideswiped
um Long Island cops after holding a gun
in the air and pointing it at his head
she got a gun yo
yo chill son
yo that's crazy
that's crazy
yeah obviously the cops had to sideswipe
her there to you know get her to put the
gun down now kyber Calderone also known
as Hannah Carrillo toted that pistol
while standing in the middle of an
intersection that was at North Belmar
and New York around 2 20 p.m again
during the day according to Nassau
County Police his rap sheet included a
June 8th arrest for third degree
burglary followed by another arrest the
next day for second-degree burglary and
trespassing
so you see it don't you the revolving
door of Justice it's so compassionate
isn't it
and things are upside down completely in
Chicago Police supervisors there are
telling cops on the beat to just avoid
chasing criminals evolved and organized
Street muggings
now by the way the results of this
hands-off approach while the offenders
in this case drove away to commit even
more crimes yeah
law enforcement can't keep the peace and
police cannot maintain order if they
themselves are handcuffed by politicians
that they answer to
and as the great Charles Murray notes it
all began when so-called Broken Window
policing stopped and a group of 34 of
the largest U.S cities homicides surged
30 percent in 2020 daily life in some
cities evoked the Menace and decay of
New York cities in the city in the 70s
and 80s
and as of 2020 arrests for broken
windows offenses since 2013 had fallen
by 74 percent in New York 77 percent in
Washington 81 percent in LA and the
collapse of broken windows policing was
accompanied by a broader Retreat from
law enforcement in all three cities for
felonies as well as misdemeanors
well the destination of perfect
criminals Paradise however still has to
go to San Francisco right where the
owner of the iconic 166 year old Gump's
department store is trying to sign the
alarm
you can't get around and when you're
trying to walk the streets you step over
needles and human waste and often bodies
on the streets it makes it an unworkable
business environment these kinds of
things are incompatible with successful
business and if that's uh if that's uh
something that business businesses have
to do to depart it's just tragic it's
really tragic
here's the bottom line
Democrats believe that any American who
works hard and tries to build a better
life for themselves and their family
probably a fascist maybe even a trump
supporter they prefer criminals because
they believe in America high crime rates
are what we frankly deserve at this
point and now for too many Americans
that's what you're getting
so if you live in one of those places
where crime is out of control and seems
to actually pay for most criminals
you have to hope that the voters turn on
the Democrat Party because until they do
this situation will continue to
deteriorate and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else